brian mauch asks
ask why the industry has gone to [ __ ]
and why studios and publishers are
comfortable releasing unfinished games
full of bugs at full aaa prices
because they can because people can buy
them but also games have legitimately
gotten harder and harder to make
because they're so complicated and
so expensive
i
uh
you know with my programming language
stuff i'm working on one axis of that
where i'm i'm trying to make the
technical part of game creation less
insane
um and
and just more
simple and robust and easy to deal with
that seems to be succeeding but who know
like having a programming language be
adopted by the world is like a whole
thing and who knows if that will happen
um
also the thing to say is that people
have been saying some variation of that
the entire time i've been in the games
industry right it used to be
triple a games are so unimaginative and
uh
you know don't don't do anything
creative um
that's actually still true right um
it used to be well there was a time when
it was that they were super buggy when
we were first starting to do 3d
uh because it was so hard and then we
kind of figured it out and they became
less buggy for a while but now they're
more buggy again because they're more
complicated
i'm not sure that games are uniquely bad
in that respect now it's just aaa doing
their thing
as they have